me quitting my job was the single
hardest decision that i've ever made in
my entire life
so rewind a handful of years ago i was
sitting on my balcony i was 22 years old
and i was staring out over this condo
that i had purchased because the job
that i had
you know paid me well and i was looking
over the city of baltimore
and i thought to myself is this it and
this was a rock top and rock bottom
moment for me specifically because
at that time i had graduated in three
years from vanderbilt mad come laude i
was president of all these things
while i was at school i got a good
consulting job and i had saved almost 50
000 at that point and i had this condo
that was increasing in value
and i saved pretty much everything minus
my mortgage and i was
as i was looking out there all i could
think to myself was how
i hated my life and how i hated my job
and i just didn't i felt so empty inside
and i was so depressed
that i really every day i would consider
as i was driving like what if i went
into the other lane and just like things
would end
and so that was like my actual reality
and so that's called passive ideation
which is like i'm not saying that i
would want to
you know kill myself but if i died and
didn't wake up tomorrow i wouldn't be
upset and that was kind of the existence
that i lived for two years of my life
and it was very hard time for me and so
i don't know where you're at in your
entrepreneurial journey but i kind of
wanted to answer
one of the questions that i get most
frequently which is you know when should
i quit and start my own business
and so i think a lot of it depends on
you specifically in self-awareness and
i'm going to talk about skill set
in a second but i want to talk about the
mindset first me
quitting my job was the single hardest
decision that i've ever made in my
entire life and i mean that genuinely
it was the hardest decision that i've
made it took me six months
to do it and i listened to arnold's
rules of success speech every morning
when i wake up
about you know it's okay to fail and i
had to keep saying this stuff because i
was so outwardly driven i was so status
driven
that i didn't want to take the risk of
being seen as a failure
and so it only was when i was literally
confronted with my own
you know the fact that i was really not
even willing to be alive anymore is when
that was kind of my
jogging to awaken this moment where i
was like you know what if i don't even
want to be alive anymore
then what's worse than that and so that
was what ultimately
shot me on the trajectory to you know
quit that job
sell the condo put everything that i had
in my car and i drove across the country
in 36 hours to california which is where
i thought
the land of fitness opportunity would be
now mind you i was a
management consultant we did space cyber
intelligence for the military
at a subcontractor or a booze allen if
you're familiar with that consulting
firm
and that's what i did for two years and
it sounds really you know cool and sexy
but it was not at all for me and i
really did not enjoy it
but i learned some valuable lessons like
how to learn while i was there
and so i think that what most people you
know it really depends on who you are
and understanding your skill set and
honestly and how much pain you're in
and so there's also different ways to
satisfy that pain i think
true to my core if i
had been in a different company or i was
working on different projects at that
time in my life
i probably would have never quit it was
so hard for me
and i didn't have a wife i didn't have
kids i had zero dependence and i lived
on nothing
and it was still one of the hardest
decisions of my life because i'm very
risk-averse so believe it or not most
entrepreneurs
you know a lot of people talk about how
they you know they didn't do well in
school and you know teachers never
understood them they always knew they
had to go out on their own i never had
any of that i worked really hard in
school i did really well in school
teachers liked me for the most part and
you know i got a good job afterwards and
so i did not have the traditional
entrepreneur journey
and it was only because i was so sad
deeply depressed in that time of my life
and felt so empty that i actually made
the jump
and so i think the first thing is like
one are you are you incredibly sad
are you incredibly dissatisfied with
your life so much so that you'd be
willing to uproot and change
number one number two entrepreneurship
is not easy
and so if you need i think elon musk
said this on a clubhouse meeting
and i just think it's so true people are
like what words of motivation would you
give for
a new entrepreneur if you need
motivational quotes or motivational
words then entrepreneurship isn't for
you
and i tend to agree with him like if you
need that motivation
like it is one of the loneliest paths
period you know at least in co-workers
you have other people who are around you
you can
but when you start on your own you're
starting at zero with no one and
basically no one's rooting for you
like for me when i left like no one
really supported me
my parents thought i was stupid and that
this was a stupid idea i was throwing my
education away
and i was risking everything just go
start a gym right which is really not
even that good of a return on investment
you know what i mean but i was so
committed to the fact that i was so
miserable
that i was like at least i can just live
my life doing something that i enjoy i
don't even care if i make money
and that was literally the mindset that
i was able to to quit with
and so i again i don't know where you're
at but
the first piece of this is understanding
short and long-term payoffs
i did not make a significant amount of
money for years
after i quit my job right so i'd say for
the first
four years i i essentially broke even
and made less money than i did as a
consultant all right so like think about
that for a second right now there's a
lot of mistakes i made too
and you're going to make them as well
because none of us is perfect there's so
many skills that you have to
like you have to acquire so many skills
to run a business
right and so you may have a single job
right now and you're you're
doing one specific function of one
specific sub department
of a business but in order to be an
entrepreneur you have to understand all
of it
right in order to be a successful
entrepreneur so you have to understand
how to generate demand you have to
generate understand how to generate
leads you have to understand how to work
leads you have to understand how to sell
you have to understand how to fulfill
and deliver and how to manage people how
to communicate how to relay expectations
how like
how to recruit how to hire how to
interview like there's so many things
that you have to learn and i don't want
that to be overwhelming i just want to
confront you with reality because
honestly if i knew
how hard it was going to be when i
started my first business i don't know
if i would have done it
i just i forced myself into a hole and i
always like to say this is you'd be
surprised what you can accomplish when
you have no choice
as as dark and morbid as i'm gonna as
what i'm gonna say is and don't get
triggered by this
but like the fact that an entire race in
our country was enslaved
for hundreds of years and was still able
to do that every day
shows the strength of the human spirit
and what is possible when you have no
choice
and so i think that to juxtapose what i
said about how hard it is
if you can put yourself in a position
where you have no choice you will be
successful
right if you want to succeed as bad as
you can breathe you will be successful
and so i think that was the situation
where i was in where i was
i knew that the alternative to what i
was doing was death for me
and so it was just anything is better
than this and honestly the next
you know year of my life even after that
was still incredibly hard but it was
different but it was still
incredibly hard and so just to give you
a couple of stats on this that i think
i think everyone should have data to
make decisions um
it's proper expectations right so the
average so this is according to small
business
administration the median excuse me the
median income
of a small business owner 49 000
a year so i don't know what you're
making right now but this is what the
middle
of the small business ownership makes
now you might be making more than that
there are people who are number 30 at
google we make way more than this
right and they're and so you have to
understand kind of where you sit on the
hierarchy and
there are some people who would be so
much better served there are
so many of my ex-employees who ended up
going out on their own
and i don't think many of them make more
than they did when they were with us and
they probably have more stress and
that's okay that was their choice
and there are trade-offs you make for
freedom right there are trade-offs
right risk and reward there are both of
those things in the aspect of this
decision
now that's supposed to say average sorry
now if you're curious what's the average
small business owner make according to
the sba
73 000 a year now averages are skewed
because there's top end people that move
that average up
so that should say average sorry but
median's 49 that means that the most
likely most repeated
outcome is 49 000 a year which is pretty
much the median household income of the
united states kind of interesting
and then the average is 73 000. so it
depends on where you're at and how
dissatisfied you are
and so the first thing is are you
dissatisfied because
you don't like the company you work for
are you dissatisfied because you don't
like the work you do
now both of those have solutions that
are outside of starting your own
business
right you can just go and find a
different position and learn on someone
else's dollar which is i think
is so wildly under underappreciated like
go to a company that you like and learn
and get paid to learn
that's amazing right like because you're
not going to learn anything at school
that's going to be useful for business
right so if you want to be an
entrepreneur you're going to have to
learn these things in the real world
and so going and getting paid to learn
is one of the best things you can
possibly imagine
you just have to understand that what
you're getting paid for is not going to
be your income for life
it's literally you getting paid to learn
how to do something which is
amazing i did not have that i literally
went from making money to starting to
learn
everything from scratch and i and it was
very difficult for me now
the the piece here about short short
term versus long term if you make this
decision
expect a three four maybe five
year decrease in income right you're not
going to make as much money for the
first few years
right and then maybe if you are
successful and you reinvest in yourself
and you grow and you acquire skills and
beliefs and attitudes and character
traits
then you will be able to have the
long-term payoff but entrepreneurship is
the ultimate
value investment in yourself and so
again there are lots of people who don't
have the risk tolerance for that and
that is okay
the vast majority of people should not
be entrepreneurs the second thing in
terms of the choices right in the
beginning it's do i need to switch
companies that's if i don't like what
i'm doing
uh sorry if i don't like the company i'm
working for number two is do i need to
switch what i'm doing and get paid to
learn
which is a second alternative to
quitting your position
number three is if i if i like what i'm
doing and i like the company
am i just not getting paid enough well
then talk to them and see how you can
provide
more value do not ask i would like to
get paid more
say how can i provide more value if you
ask that question
any any smart business owner be able to
tell you exactly how to provide more
value
so that you can make more in a low risk
environment and then the fourth way you
can do this
if you're considering quitting is start
investing all of your extra time
in acquiring the other skills and start
actually doing it
spend some money on marketing do some
outreach do those types of things to
generate demand for your business
now in the beginning it's going to be a
side hustle but over time it can grow
and then at a certain point it will grow
in excess of what you are currently
making and then you can make the jump
i did not do that what i did was
candidly very stupid i got lucky
i got very lucky i got extraordinarily
lucky that i had people who were able to
speak into my life at an early time
point
i was able to learn from experts very
very quickly which candidly i invested
in that i paid
all of my savings that i'd saved up the
50 000 was gone
within the first three months of me
starting entrepreneurship gone because i
paid for mentorship i paid for coaching
programs and i bought and i and i
reinvested in a gym which i shouldn't
have done
um i shouldn't have opened it the way i
did because i didn't know any better
right and so the biggest issue your
biggest risk when you start on your own
is that you don't know what you're doing
right and so the idea is if you can
decrease your downside risk by learning
more skills getting paid to learn them
asking your business how you can provide
more value which will allow you to learn
more skills and get paid more as you do
it
right if you do all of those things and
after doing all those steps you still
are not satisfied then be willing to
make the risk and make the short-term
trade-off that you're going to make less
for a period of time
and so this is why i'm so such a big
believer in in
in living cheap right live cheap and
keep your expectations at cheap
so that if your your income does drop
you're still not losing money
and then long term you can keep
reinvesting in yourself so that you as
the valuable asset
can become more valuable and then
increase in your earning potential
and by extension because of the skills
you learn grow your business so
to answer the question um when do you
when you couldn't start a business it
depends on who you are and where you're
at in your life
there are lots of other steps you can do
before that like switch a company switch
the job
ask if you can do things that are making
you more valuable start the side hustle
first
then start making sure that it works if
you like it before betting everything on
it
and then finally if none of those things
uh work for you
then at that point i would say okay if
you have
reasonable means that you've that you've
saved up you have a vehicle that you
know is tested you know other people who
are doing that specific thing
and you can do it then i would say by
all means but i think that i made a lot
of stupid decisions and candidly i think
i got really lucky
and so um that is that is the the long
way to answer to this question which is
when
when do you when do you quit start your
own business it depends on you i can't
give you a perfect answer because i
don't know who you are
but those are the frameworks that i'd be
thinking of and these are the
expectations that i would set
in understanding the average 18 year old
a senior in high school when surveyed
believes that they will be a millionaire
by age 25.
how ridiculously unreasonable is that
that they believe this is the average
right believes that they're going to be
in the top 1 within 7 years of
graduating high school let's be real
here do we think that that
is a reasonable expectation no so if you
believe that
the stats are against you doesn't mean
i'm saying i don't believe in you
i believe in you 100 i'm your biggest
fan but
understand that these are the actual
expectations of what this means
all right i remember when i quit my job
and i found out what the top gym owners
were making
and i remember literally my first
thought was that's it
and so you have to understand that
there's there's the hullabaloo of
revenue
which i made in another video about
measuring value lots of people talk big
numbers
not a lot of people make big numbers
most people are broke and the reason i
have this channel is to make sure that
you are not one of them
and so uh hope you enjoyed this click
subscribe if you did and i'll see in the
next video